oh we're on hello okay steve here
uh i'm back in vancouver
happy to be back home it's uh
overcast and it's a cool
oh i gotta turn off the sound here
yeah 10 or 12 degrees or whatever it's
supposed to go up to 15.
uh but it's great to be back
uh and i want to talk a little bit about
what i call the eureka moment in
language learning and some from some of
my own experience and share that with
you as we near the end now of our 90-day
challenge where we're trying to make a
breakthrough in i'm trying to make a
breakthrough
in two languages of course persian and
arabic
so i decided i'm finding arabic more
difficult than persian
so i decided to focus on arabic
uh the previous week
um
of course the week before that i had my
two sons visiting in palm springs so i
didn't have much time and of course
every day we're down there while it's
still sunny we want to go golfing every
day so the amount of time left over for
language learning is
limited
but i focused on arabic and then because
i had my
online tutor session
with rana in persian coming up on
thursday
so i said okay from wednesday noon
until whatever time is available and we
did play golf and i went to the gym and
around the house picking things up
whatever i was doing i was focused on
persian
now one of the things that we now have
at least on the beta
on my app is the ability to go into a
course and say listen to the audio for
the course so i can hear the whole
course because previously in the
playlist
sometimes you know depending on when i
added something to the playlist it may
not all be in sequence
but i wanted to hear who is she in
persian in sequence so i listened to
that and i listened to a few other
things also rana created some very good
mini stories
in persian seven many stories and i also
listened to that whole series and then i
went through and looked up some of the
words the links words that i still
hadn't you know learned
so i put an effort into persian
and i had my conversation with rana it
was the best conversation i have had she
noted it
she even went you know club
and for me i i was able to i felt i was
able to control the conversation i was
able to recall things
of course words at times i wasn't able
to find she provided them but mostly the
words that that i knew that i knew i was
able to use the words that i didn't know
i didn't know when she provided them
so it was a really it was a great moment
because you sort of suddenly realize
that you're making progress
now
those eureka moments are important
because they keep us going
uh because so often we feel we're not
making progress
and and of course the eureka moment is
not limited to when you are you able to
use the language it's also in terms of
listening and reading
so
you know i uh you know i was just
thinking the other day i wrote this book
i think about
i don't know
12 years ago
uh more 2002 what's that 16 17 years ago
i spoke nine languages at that time
i'm now working on languages 19 and 20
arabic and persian
but when i started into russian about
this a little after i wrote the book i
mean russian that's got to be very
difficult it's a cyrillic alphabet they
got all this complicated grammar
and i can remember
still jogging around
here in west vancouver listening to
tergenyev listening to an audiobook
and i listened to it many times
and you know previous to that i had
listened to other things in russian
uh which were
at an earlier stage i had fewer words i
couldn't really understand it like the
uh i can't remember what the name of it
was
about the the postmaster's daughter i
guess it was chekhov
anyway so tulgania if i'm actually
enjoying it i was living in the mid-19th
century in russia that was like a eureka
moment
and uh so there are many like right now
for example in ukraine there's a debate
between
the president president current
president poroshenko and his rival
zelensky
and i will listen i'll find it somewhere
on youtube i'm going to listen to it
and or maybe the debate is over but i
was busy doing something else but i'm
going to listen to it and i'll
understand it
when i first started watching shuster
live on ukrainian tv via the internet i
could understand the russians i couldn't
understand the ukrainians now i
understand ukrainian before i started
into russian i i you know i couldn't
even have dream dreamt of
reading tolstoy or listening to tergenia
so you have these moments and and it's
important that it's not just the
speaking success it's the listening and
reading success because if you have
reading and listening success you will
eventually have more and more speaking
success and you don't have to be perfect
when i go i'm going to be in ukraine
second half of may
i'll make mistakes for sure in both my
russian and ukrainian i'll make mistakes
but the important things to look back on
where you were
and now what you have been able to
achieve
the other small thing about speaking
maybe not so small is
we become good at speaking a language if
we get to speak a lot so if we don't
have the need to speak a lot and
therefore we don't have the opportunity
to speak a lot then our speaking is
going to lag behind we can build up our
capability our potential
through
massive input lots of listening and
reading
working at link for example but that's
building up our potential eventually to
be able to speak well we have to speak a
lot but if we don't have the either the
need or the opportunity why worry about
it when that need and opportunity ira
you know arrives arises
we will then quickly improve if we build
up our capability and so in order to
encourage us to keep going and now we've
got one more week to go on our 90 day
challenge
remember
you know recognize where you once were
in the language and the level you are at
now and there are moments when you
get that sort of giddy feeling of wow
look at me look what i'm able to do
and and focus on those and don't focus
on those moments when you're
disappointed and frustrated and
forgotten can't say what you want to say
and keep on making the same mistakes
because that's going to be there it's
going to be there but in amongst all of
that
is unmistakable progress which we
recognize in these occasional eureka
moments so that's what i had to say now
we'll see what sorts of questions you
all have
okay
good day i'm first in here blah blah
what made you start a youtube channel is
the first question
i knew nothing about it someone said i
should so 12 years ago i started a video
and um
yeah i just kept going i went from no
you know one or two subscribers i had no
idea what it would be like to launch a
video out there that some people
somewhere might find and how they would
react and
but it just kept growing and uh yeah no
particular purpose
scott i'm going to start all up to me
the first eureka moment was when i was
reading part of a french novel and for
the first time i was seeing the story in
my head like a movie not a translation
scott preston an excellent point you
know there comes a point
when the language the foreign language
that we're learning is meaning all by
itself is meaning
we're not translating it it's meaning
and as you say it's like a movie because
through words that's why i like reading
and listening because it's just words
and we're conjuring up
all of these
you know scenes and personalities
through those words that we're getting
in the foreign language
and i always remember for example
when i listen to uh
say in in mandarin chinese they have
these storytellers you know sangoyenyi
told by a storyteller
and it's so much more powerful than the
movie because it's only words so you
have to conjure up everything based on
the words and
when we get to that point and that's why
audiobooks are so great when we get to
that point where we're conjuring things
up in our mind directly meaning foreign
language equals meaning without going
through our own language that's a eureka
moment
what else we got
what is the genesis story of link
that's another long story but
i guess when i was about 55 i decided i
should really learn cantonese
in vancouver there's lots of cantonese
speakers i spoke mandarin i could
stumble in cantonese you know nehomah
but i couldn't really speak it
so i decided to start learning cantonese
as part of that i listened to cantonese
radio in vancouver and i heard that
there was a chinese immigrant who had
arrived at the airport and had his life
savings ten thousand dollars stolen at
the airport there are gangs that prey
upon these people because very often
these chinese immigrants they arrived
with all their money in a bag and they
leave it on their cart which isn't very
smart
so i contacted this chinese organization
in vancouver and said um you know too
bad about him but he's in the it
business we at my company we were
building software for sawmills maybe we
can use him maybe we can't we'll give
him a job we can at least help him for a
few months if it works out for us and
for him that's good if not at least we
help them out a bit
uh he came he had high scores in toefl
but his communication skills were sorely
lacking so we developed something for
him
he eventually went back to china
we then tried to interest the
immigration department in canada in what
we had developed of course
the bureaucracy is something else
and so we said okay this is not going to
be a system just for learning english
we're going to make it a multi-language
platform where people help each other
learn languages and that's the genesis
of link
now
hey what's up folks where's our fearless
leader
steve changed the background language
learning is painful okay language
learning is need not be painful
need not be painful you have to find
ways to enjoy it
perfection is not the goal
uh you have to kind of temper your
expectations
but find ways to enjoy it because if you
enjoy it you will spend the time
if you enjoy it you'll have a positive
attitude if you enjoy it and spend the
time have a positive attitude you will
succeed
so
find a way find content find things find
voices find people find things that you
enjoy in the language and you will do
well
okay hello
hi barron here from journey high band
uh
shukran
thank you hello
if it hurts you are doing it wrong just
listen to yourself and enjoy yourself
yes
don't torture yourself enjoy the process
yes can you learn a hundred characters
in one month yes you can
uh
steve president okay president of what
uh will you get confused if you're
learning spanish and french at the same
time
uh
no and i think if you are advanced in
spanish it's a good time to start french
what is this book about well the book
describes my own experience in learning
nine languages during my professional
career
and some of my ideas about language
learning
um
and some advice on language learning
yeah it's it's
still available at amazon
uh what kind of place can you get nice
shelves like those behind you everything
seems to be flat packed
and vip no this is ikea
and i've got shelves for my books and
shelves for my
cds and i can tell you i got lots of
them and a lot of them have to do with
language but there's also
others
and one interesting thing is as i look
at and i've got books on turkish and
languages that i haven't even started
learning and i know that if i apply
myself and if i enjoy the process which
i will
uh then i will succeed
okay
mr steve eureka okay well maybe we have
some greek scholars here as to the
origin of the word eureka
but eureka is is that moment
when we discover something we suddenly
realize something it's a
flash
moment of of aha
wow
that's how you reach a moment
how would you maintain six languages
daily with enough time to put it would
you work with all of them
no hi luis
or jaya luis
uh
i find that my languages don't
decline deteriorate atrophy
uh
if i can i can leave them for six months
for a year
get back in there i'm a little rusty but
very soon i get back to where i was
uh
perfect example is going to be uh korean
which i'm going to jump back into
uh after i get back from ukraine and i
have no doubt that i will be a little
rusty but i have also no doubt that
within a very short period of time i
will be better than i ever was we don't
lose the languages they rest they in
many ways
settle in and we almost become stronger
when we go back at them so that's not a
concern
nice glasses yeah i picked these up
actually in portugal they're great
because
you know i can just have them around my
neck
and then i can read when i need to read
thanks for going i guess i'll have to
come back thanks for encouragement blah
blah blah nice glasses
hello
do you know
when the user stories are going to be
published
uh
it i think today's a holiday here
but um the user stories i'll have to
follow up i can't answer
okay eureka moment in german yeah eureka
moment in german
so
i guess was i was between jobs in 1987
and i decided to really go after german
uh once i i had you know i had worked as
a young
person i had worked my way across the
atlantic on a
german freighter so i spoke in some
german i had my german book with all the
de adidas
and i had also worked on construction in
vienna for a short period of time where
i used some german so i had some
sense of german
uh in fact my parents were born in
czechoslovakia and they spoke german at
home although my brother and i never
did so i went at it the first thing i
did was stop trying to remember the
declension tables it's a useless
it's a fruitless
futile thing to do you won't remember
them
and so i went around the bookstores
secondhand bookstores in vancouver found
a whole bunch of readers with vocabulary
so that got me started so i did a lot of
reading i had a month off i just a lot
of reading of these things with the
vocab with the
glossaries
and then i found these uh
cassette tapes uh
and they were just a series of
interviews from german radio so they
were just dialogues conversations and i
listened to them over and over and over
again
and eventually i got to where i could
really understand them and that was a
eureka moment
then i set up my own business and i had
we did some business in germany i had a
bunch of germans came over and i
couldn't really communicate very well
but i ended up going to germany
traveling with my agent sitting in the
car on the autobahn stuck in traffic for
hours and through a lot of
then talking i was able to activate
everything that i had done but i guess
two things one understanding those
initial
uh
cassette tapes and then being able to
carry on conversations on the autobahn
okay
steve
how
to tackle learning a language that does
not have many resources fertilizer i for
example learning cantonese and it's very
hard to find good intermediate resources
i mean first of all we do have
cantonese at linc now i believe
um
i listened to cantonese radio here
when i started out because i spoke
mandarin i got people to read things in
cantonese things that i could read in
mandarin then i listened a lot to
cantonese radio
and uh there are podcasts out of hong
kong you should also try
to see if i haven't checked on uh
vocalmatic these uh automatic
transcription services i haven't uh
checked to see if they do cantonese but
you can get like history podcasts and
other podcasts out of hong kong
if if you can read and uh you can get
these transcribed that would be
intermediate content
other than that i would look for
cantonese radio on the internet
uh so the question from giovanni is do
you have to be smart to learn a language
i don't think so
uh
but
it's possible that some people do better
than others
uh
but but the the
differences are not that great i think
we have to just stay with the program
and learn languages for yourself don't
learn
you know
looking over your shoulder like
someone else is better than me or worse
than me or speaks with a better accent
or stuff that doesn't matter you learn
languages for yourself for your own
enjoyment and so whether someone else
seems to be moving along more quickly or
not really shouldn't be
a consideration
okay sajid mushfig raman is now learning
arabic it's a toughy i guess
uh edwin finch yeah
course playback
it's it's actually you know being able
to listen to the whole course
as a playlist is it's tremendous it's
it's
we should have done it earlier but at
any rate it's coming
do you ever have the problem of knowing
all the words but not really getting the
meaning of course
and uh that's why sometimes if you're
reading and fighting your way through
word for word what's written there and
you don't really get the meaning then
when you listen to it you get more
momentum you get more of a flavor
so that's why it's important to read and
listen but still
the brain has to get used to a new
language how things are expressed you
can know all the words you can know all
the grammar rules
and still
there is a pattern there that your brain
is not yet used to and you just have to
keep feeding and feeding it and feeding
it and i noticed this when i was
listening to who is she in persian which
i struggled through
uh
you know months ago and now i just
understand it all
so the brain just trusts the brain with
enough exposure some repetition some new
stuff the brain will eventually start
you know organizing these things uh
establishing the connections
uh
to be able to understand
i understand the languages regulations
of 2013 i'm still not fluent any
language i know
to testify in language i know now that
it is so important to stick with one
language okay
uh
so
um yeah i mean it depends what you're
motivated to do but to do well you got
to focus
and i mean i've here i've done two
languages arabic and persian but i think
if i really wanted to do well in arabic
i would just focus on arabic
so focus is good
as long as you don't get bored
i wrote some content for link in arabic
what do i do after importing it well
first of all this is from some kid
first of all uh
hopefully you have recorded it as well
because we can't have it without
the audio
and then second of all when you import
it there's an opportunity there to share
it and you can share it if you don't if
there are no copyright issues
what are the most useful languages i
mean you can google to see which of the
most widely spoken languages as to which
are the most useful languages that
depends on what you need the languages
for
[Music]
the french podcast with uh oh he i did
gosh it's got to be all 10 years ago or
so
uh
yeah it's difficult to find people to
talk to
amanda panda asked me if i think my
language learning approach is noble i
don't know whether she seem whether you
mean novel
but i mean my language learning approach
is everything i talk about here in these
videos in other words focus on
input focus on enjoying the language
don't worry when you speak look for
opportunities to speak but when you feel
like it but don't worry about mistakes
and enjoy the process and get the brain
has to get used to the language it needs
a lot of exposure
thank you john kr when archimedes
discovered his theorem for
a fist
when he
this whole theory about
he puts himself in the bathtub i think
then he displaces
water equal to i can't remember it's all
from school but
so eureka means means i found it
oh here we go
every means i found it
in ancient greek is it possible if you
learn five languages yes
good
you haven't learned languages for many
years bangladesh is his most spoken
language now do you ever feel interested
about it okay
i
do want to learn
one south asian language
uh i'm moving my way gradually
in a southeasterly direction
from uh you know
greece to arabic persian
and but it might start with hindi
might start with hindi
okay thank you daniel
thank you faisal steve last time i heard
you talking about the quantity of
languages equals 13. my question is how
many of these languages do you feel
okay antonio de lima
so
i i sort of classify them this way there
are ten languages that i can speak now
or less well with mistakes whatever i
can speak them and then there's another
10 that i have to warm up
and um so czech or polish
gonna be a little more difficult
uh greek you know romanian would take a
lot more warming up
but right now with persian and arabic
because i'm doing them
i can speak although not very well so 10
that i can turn on and 10 that require a
bit of work
i don't really like tv series or films
could you say some tips to enjoy
learning languages from lara yeah i'm
not a fan of
tv and i don't like learning languages
from
video or film
video or film is great for me it's it
can be fun it can be a reward it gives
you a eureka moment you understand
everything but for learning
i prefer
things that are more
word
dense
reading and listening
in other words what we have at link
combining the reading and listening and
focusing on words and phrases and and
getting the words into your brain the
video where you see people moving around
is a distraction and
typically videos are not as word dense
because there's a lot of action
you're able to infer the meaning from
the action you're not relying just on
the words
uh to convey meaning so
the fact that you don't like tv and film
is not an obstacle to learning languages
how do you feel about language teachers
who speak the target language as a
secondary
since they went through what i did and
speak more closely to me
um yeah personally
you know
i would always prefer to learn from a
native speaker
because the native speaker
represents
you know
the goal i won't achieve the goal but
that's where i want to get to that's the
person i want to imitate
the native speaker to my mind is more
authentic if i learn korean from an
american
uh or a japanese
somehow i there's a credibility issue
um
so
however
most language teachers are not native
speakers
uh
they
uh
you know obviously if they are good
motivators because don't forget i
believe the biggest
most important
uh characteristic of a good language
teacher is that they are good motivators
and good communicators
uh
hi steve bye fff
did you hear quran on youtube
okay to learn arabic from the quran
you know to learn a lot i like to learn
from content of interest to me
and the second thing is i think the
content it's easier to learn from
content that's familiar
so
uh very often in learning a foreign
language if you get if you buy a chinese
textbook they want to talk about
things that are very chinese is certain
festivals and the same with the japanese
and they get too deep into the culture
of the language
at an early stage when we don't really
understand the language very well it is
much easier for me to learn the language
from everyday situations
so
if
jamil and
his wife besma get up in the morning and
have a cup of coffee and he goes to work
and she goes to work and their kids go
to school all of that is much easier for
me because it's a familiar situation
it's ordinary people in their ordinary
lives that is easy learning content
the quran to me would be it's from you
know 1500 years ago it deals with things
that i'm not very familiar with i'm not
very motivated
to learn arabic from such content i am
more interested in hearing about
political events today i'm also not a
religious person so i'm not very
interested in religion so for all of
those reasons i'm not very motivated to
learn arabic from the quran which is not
to say that at some point i won't listen
to it
i'm not going to answer your question
could you show us your room
well i can show you a little bit
so let's see what happens here
so here you have
it's a bit messy so i've got all my
books in there see what you can see in
the background
and uh some pictures when the
grandchildren come
they can sleep in these bunk beds
and i will even show you
if this works
this is a view outside
so you can see how green vancouver is
okay
and uh we're kind of near the water
and there you go
uh now what we got here
so
do you
assalamu alaikum
do you measure learning based on levels
like cefr
i don't typically worry too much about
that however i am going
to uh ukraine
and uh
first of all be in eastern ukraine and
then i'm going to go to lev
where i have a teacher who worked with
me on my ukrainian before and i'm going
to ask her just out of curiosity to give
me an unofficial evaluation of my
ukrainian and maybe my russian and tell
me if i'm b1b2 or whatever level she
thinks i am but ordinarily i don't
really fuss too much about those levels
uh i you know
if people ask me
very roughly i'll say i think that my
french is probably c1 my japanese is a
strong b2 as is my mandarin
most of the first 10 languages are in
that b2 range and then they drop down to
b1
most of them
i missed one here
spanish resources i'm sorry i can't tell
you now matthew but you can check see
what we have at link or you can ask on
our forum
do you think writing is the best way of
practicing english i don't think it's
necessarily the best way but it's a very
good way
because you can take your time look for
words look up words look up grammar
rules and practice speaking
your writing correctly and and in my
view we should always if we're learning
a language kind of treat writing and
speaking as the same
don't try to have an excessively
complicated
style in writing or an excessively
informal style in speaking i try to be
neutral so that when i speak i'm neutral
not excessively slangy and when i write
i write the same way that i speak and so
writing yes is very useful but i don't
know if it's the most useful
used to write a book in english and
publish how long i have to wait to
improve my english
you know people ask how quickly can i
learn how long
just keep going
you'll continue to get better no i can't
tell you
i miss the chance so someone is not
ashamed how do you manage your time do
you organize your time into ridge slots
no i don't bentley i don't i am
retired
but i do have other activities uh
obviously um you know i can't be
anti-social my family
i do things with my wife i travel
so when i have the time so the the
number one
learning activity is listening
that's why the playlist is important
that's why i'm so glad now that we're
getting the the course playlist
listening you can do edit anytime just
pick up my
iphone or my uh
whatever it might be put in my earpods
and away i go
while cleaning up while going for a walk
while going to the store while working
out so you can always listen you can
always find time to listen so when you
listen you discover
what you're missing whereas you don't
know
structures that you're confused about so
then i go into the story and i look
these things up and maybe read the story
a few times
um
you know we flew from palm springs to
vancouver so for three hours i'm on the
plane or two and a half hours so that's
a dedicated
reading linking time
uh
so i don't have any i don't say today
i'm going to do an hour between 10 and
11. i don't have that the only thing
that's lined up is my
uh
conversations with my tutors of which
i've had
recently one a week in arabic and one a
week in
persian
okay
okay so that's basically it routine
strategy there is none do what i want to
do when i feel like doing it
how can i improve my accent in english
at the same time speaking okay accent
first of all stop worrying about your
accent
anything we do in language is negatively
influenced by pressure
so if you are concerned about something
you'll do less well so don't worry about
your accent
lots of listening
and you can listen to a sentence or a
paragraph
listen to it and then try to imitate the
intonation if you can get the intonation
right very often the pronunciation of
the words will kind of
catch up
one other thing it's important to know i
know many people
okay
if a person speaks english well uses
words well he has a wide vocabulary
speaks accurately and has an accent and
that's person a
and person b has very little accent but
doesn't use the language well makes
mistakes
then person a is much more impressive
than person b
so
accent is uh
i would say
there's far too much emphasis placed on
accent what's more important is to have
a good control of the language
um
okay
will you continue to do these types of
streams after the 90 day challenge maybe
once a week i'm thinking of doing that
i'm thinking of doing that that maybe
have one monologue and then one
of these
um
faisal can you give me advice on how to
memorize words yeah don't memorize the
words expose yourself to more and more
if you try to memorize a limited range
of vocabulary sort of block learn
something the harder you try to memorize
it the less learning is taking place
and there's
studies in cognitive science that show
this you're far better off
to move on to new material where a lot
of words that you are trying to learn
are going to reappear anyway
stimulate your brain with exposure to
the language rather than trying to sort
of memorize a limited
uh arbitrary list of words
uh
okay jack i miss what's up thrust yeah i
think it's displacement but at any rate
thank you john kr you answered the
question
thanks for responding
okay thank you for your answer steve i'd
like to know how all these podcasts are
i answered that over 10 years
have you had feedback or any acting on
how well the link style learning works
with middle school high school age case
uh ian yeah i haven't really had any
feedback we do have some schools some
classroom teachers that we work with
where we have a you know link for the
classroom we can set it up for their
group he can control the content that
they access follow the learners and
stuff and i think the kids like it
but it's very important that this be
assigned by the teacher because most
kids in school or for that matter in
university won't do anything unless it's
assigned to them because they don't they
got enough things they feel that they
have to do they're not going to
voluntarily do stuff most of them but we
do have some we have members as young as
12 on link who are very happy using it
do iran arabic in arabic
do i don't understand but poetry again
is is well down well down uh into the
future here it's near horseshoe bay yeah
this is eagle harbor
uh
phrases or words which better for me to
learn a new language perfectly both you
need the words and you need the phrases
so
typically a link i'll save the word and
then i save a phrase around it
eventually i will unsave the phrase and
just keep the word or words if i still
don't know them but phrases are consist
of words so you have to know the meaning
of the words but in order to be able to
use the language you have to be able to
have
you know a sense of of which words are
used with which words so you also have
to learn phrases
i was wondering how i can become a tutor
i think in what language
uh
there is a tutor section
and you can go there and register
yourself as a tutor
and make time slots available and
people will sign up
does knowing many languages help you
with picking up women
i would imagine so i'm married so i
can't comment on that but uh the
you know it's a bit like business
um the more languages you know the more
opportunities are going to come your way
that doesn't mean you're going to
succeed with all those opportunities
similarly with language
just because you can speak the language
that's not guaranteeing you success with
women i think
um what do you think about multiple
intelligence can they i don't
i don't really buy the theory of
multiple intelligence to me there's
intelligence and then there are other
things
so emotional intelligence i don't i
don't necessarily
believe in all of that
i'm a firm believer that
we can all
learn reading is a great way of learning
the more we read the more we learn
the more we know the better our critical
thinking
so a lot of the sort of modern critical
thinking multiple intelligences learning
styles
i'm not i'm not a big fan
reading is the most important
does listening to target language on
lower volume than usual
make what was said good for i don't do
it in fact i think that when learning a
language you want good volume pleasant
voice pleasant experience you don't want
to be straining to understand just as
with reading you want a larger font
clear text that's why so many of the
arabic books were so bad because the
font is so small it's difficult enough
to read the arabic script or persian for
that matter but then if they make the
script small or if the text is fuzzy
you know when you're learning a foreign
language the conditions have to be as
pleasant as comfortable as possible
that's true of the audio it's true of
the reading
low volume not good
in my opinion
uh tone groups theory in english tone
groups like hydro blow do you think that
intonation is important for native
non-native speakers yeah again
i think the fewer
the less terminology high drop what was
all that again
you know high drop low bounce
i don't think that's helpful i think you
have to listen to it and imitate it
it's like this pitch thing in japanese i
never bothered about pitch i have no
idea what they're talking about i just
try to imitate what i hear and get that
get that there it's it's like that
pitchfork
you've got a there has to be some
resonance you have to kind of be open to
what you're listening to and then try to
imitate it without
getting too much into the theory of the
thing the same is true of of
correct usage you can occasionally look
at the grammar but mostly you have to
allow the brain to get used to
what it is exposed to
blah
your wife is from hong kong did you
practice your cantonese with her um no
essentially
um
we do sometimes say things in cantonese
to each other if we don't want people
around us to understand what we're
saying i got into trouble getting off
the plane yesterday
because there was this mother and her
daughter
and for whatever reason i thought they
were japanese but they took forever to
get off the train plane and they were
readjusting their bags and they were
blocking everything and i i said
i told you sad you know like they're
just blocking everybody
and uh they were cantonese speakers so
my wife wasn't very happy about that but
the problem is this if you are used if
you are in a relationship with someone
and you're used to speaking language a
which might be your native language it's
very difficult to get that person to
speak another language
because
your relationship is based on you're
communicating in a certain language it's
not so easy to switch so she was not
in any way helpful in my learning
cantonese
yeah so here again flute ninja
header eureka moment i mean these
movements we got to be open to them and
we have to focus on these positive
moments when all of a sudden we feel
this this wow look at me i'm flying you
know
uh
because there are moments when we don't
feel so good about ourselves and we have
to remember these moments these positive
moments and focus less on the
frustrations that are a part of language
learning
i guess you can learn a language during
all your life nowhere to hurry so
exactly
exactly
there's no hurry
the language isn't going anywhere
um
you know like russian i would love to
improve my russian but i'm learning
other languages but russian isn't going
anywhere the
works of russian literature aren't going
anywhere there's going to be russian
movies i'll have another opportunity to
visit russia it'll improve over time
there's no rush and if we're enjoying it
i'm enjoying learning persian and arabic
i'm in no hurry to end the experience
although i will be ending it for other
reasons but not because i'm in a hurry
uh
okay
how one could benefit the most for
input-based learning
and start living in a country where the
language is spoken well massaging ozeki
of course if you live where the language
is spoken that's an ideal situation but
like i am learning my 19th and 20th
language i can't live in 20 in 20
countries
um
i learned mandarin chinese in hong kong
at a time when just about nobody in hong
kong spoke mandarin
in japan i was live surrounded by the
language we have immigrants in canada
who live here for 20 30 40 years and
don't learn english so
being in the country where the language
is spoken can be an advantage but it
isn't for everyone and not being there
doesn't prevent you from learning the
language and if you're planning to visit
the country to work on your language
build up your capability first through
lots of listening and reading so that
when you get to the country you can
actually take advantage of being there
um
okay do you ever find it hard to
concentrate on listening while doing
other tasks no i don't find it hard
because i don't again i don't i'm not
determined to focus all the time at
times i fade in fade out fade in fade
out but it's i i do notice those things
that i can't understand for example that
drive me back to the text so
i don't have a problem i i have more of
a problem if i sit down and try to just
listen then my mind wanders but if my
mind is occupied with another task
exercising or doing the dishes
then i miss some things in what i'm
listening to but it doesn't bother me
now thanks for all if you like
interesting content
why do you prefer learning so many
languages at b1 level rather than
achieving c1
in a few enjoying more complex
interesting content because i'm also
interested in exploring new languages
so
yeah i could spend my whole time uh
exploring the depths of chinese
literature or you know getting into
traditional chinese or doing japanese
literature or any of those things any of
the languages russian or spanish or
german
but i'm i'm finding it fascinating to
get some taste of the arabic world of
the persian world which inevitable
inevitably leads you to explore areas of
history and stuff like that so it's a
compromise
between
wanting to get into
you know
more depth or more
interesting material in languages that
i'm fairly good at
as opposed to exposing myself again to
the difficult task of
clawing my way up in a new language
until eventually i get to where i can
you know listen to interesting authentic
content
life is full of compromises
yeah that's my study when would you go
back to brazil i have no immediate plans
when i was in english i faced difficulty
although i listen too much to movies
people or anything else well the
listening itself is not enough combine
the listening with reading because if
too much of it is
not being understood then the benefits
are
diminished so make sure you do reading
combined with
listening
steve do you think that comparative
indo-european linguistics is an
interesting field i'm shocked to how
close are some seemingly irrelevant
languages i know eight languages and
this helped me john kr i mean i find
everything that compares languages
similarities differences the evolution
of one language to another
uh
influences of one language on another
all of these things are absolutely
fascinating absolutely fascinating
are you going to try hebrew you know
what as i walked up here i looked at i
have a hebrew book i will go back to
hebrew but
you know right now i have a bunch of
plans ahead of me
i think having done arabic will make
hebrew a little easier
uh yeah i would like to go back to
hebrew the problem with learning
languages is there are so many languages
we'd like to learn and there's a limited
amount of time so you know thai
indonesian
uh you know there's so there's no end
i have a russian friend who didn't want
to lose her accent because then i
wouldn't be special yeah i mean yeah
there's nothing wrong
with a um
with a russian or french or any other
accent
you hear it's nice
okay no tones are not a vast conspiracy
tones are real and the better you use
them the better impression you create
mr steve which language that you learn
do you think that is the most beautiful
um
you know
there are different times when i listen
to whatever language it might be
spanish italian russian korean japanese
when i appreciate certain things about
the language
how words are put together the
pronunciation and and uh
yeah they all have their appeal
um
italian is right up there french
russian
mandarin beijing accent version
yeah but greek
it's too too early for me to comment on
arabic and persian
to what extent is your learning ability
being diminished by age for example are
you half as fast at learning a language
now compared to 30 no i'm faster now i
learn languages faster now absolutely
no question
uh even compared to i mean how long did
it take me to learn french
um
you know when i uh early 60s took me a
long time to get to where i could speak
russian after russian it took me six
months before i could have a
conversation in czech and a halting
conversation at that and now with my
persian i actually had quite a decent
conversation after really only three
months and that is in tandem with
learning arabic
the many stories are a big reason
uh i think the brain's the same you got
to keep keep it active keep it active
not a problem
what extent is your diminished page for
those who like
learn to use video you can select audio
description in your target language for
a word dance experience yes you can also
import videos from youtube to link and
if it is with closed captions that
becomes a lesson so you can read it
listen to it
and watch the video
is it possible to understand french
movies after five months of learning
difficult
how do i learn my first language what do
i need to learn
um
just start with short
lessons like we do at link or get
yourself a simple starter book
you know
initially you have to listen to the same
content many times so lesson one you
listen four or five times lesson two
lesson three go back to lesson one when
you listen you don't understand you read
you look up words and you just keep
doing that and and in time
you know the first three months are
tough it's a very steep hill however
all of a sudden you can
understand some things and say some
things in a new language
after that it's a long long road until
you are really able to understand movies
and things of that nature
recall correctly one of your older
videos you recommended our opinion when
studying mandarin is that correct yes
yeah i find that pinion helps otherwise
it's very difficult
just to rely on the sound so the pinion
is sort of the
phonetic script for chinese and i think
it's very useful
i'm a polyglot but it's difficult to
find a job as a teacher as a non-native
teacher any tip to show up in the market
well
to my mind
there are non-native teachers of a
language and if they claim like they'll
say well
you know i i know the language well i
know the grammar i know this and that to
me and i'm not an employer of teachers
but the most important thing is
is to motivate the learners so if you
are a good motivator if you have good
communication skills you have empathy
with the learner those are all valuable
attributes
and
insofar as you know whether you might
have an accent or something there's so
many resources out there so whatever the
language might be we can find
you know unlimited amounts of audio and
text resources on the internet so the
teacher doesn't have to be the model the
teacher can introduce
you know
lessons content content of interest to
the learner
get
enable the learner to get all the input
the learner needs so therefore the
teacher doesn't have to be providing
that the teacher can be a guide and a
motivator in which case a native speaker
or at least a non-native speaker is just
as good
in my own case i provide my own
motivation
so what i look for in a tutor is is
someone that i can converse with so
that's different from a classroom
teacher
hmm
are you going to do a 90-day challenge
for russian
no
um
i'm not going to do a 90-day challenge
i'm going to be in rush in ukraine for
two weeks
before going there i'm going to work on
my russian and ukrainian a bit but it's
not going to be a 90-day challenge
how to get but link will have more
90-day challenges and people can learn
whatever language they
want don't you don't you think listening
to music can be helpful for people who
have a great music intelligence compared
with interpersonal reading one no i
don't agree with that
i see no evidence that musical people
are better at learning languages
and um no i'm just it's it's not
something that i have ever
ascribed to
my main frustration on english is when i
hear tony robbins speaking i don't
understand anything well that's good so
now you've got curiosity you heard him
you don't understand go read it
import the text in the link look up
words and phrases listen again that's
good you want to understand what he's
saying you like listening to tony
robbins i presume now you would like to
understand him you're going to have to
read happy easter
says
recommended tips to learn french same as
for all languages
good francesca
roman happy easter to you have you read
any book in chinese and how many
characters do i need three novels well i
have read uh various short story books i
have read uh lotianza
uh i think you need three four thousand
characters to read novels hey steve
why don't people care about intonation
while trying to speak other languages i
think it's tremendously important yes
intonation is important intonation is
almost more important than the
individual pronunciation of
words
um
not right now but i will get back to
chesky
uh
how much time should one devote each day
learning a foreign language as it
involves writing
well i spent an hour an hour an hour and
a half about one hour of listening half
an hour of reading
are you going to be polyglot conference
in bratislava no unfortunately
do you think we can learn anything if we
really want yeah i mean some things i
mean you have to have a sufficient
background in i don't know maths or
science in order to understand more
complicated things in math or science so
you have to go through the process you
have to have words in order to
understand what you're reading but in
theory yes we can understand whatever we
want
where did you buy the joyous food style
of glasses i bought them
in uh i bought them in lisbon
because um yeah i walked into a store i
was gonna buy the usual uh
15
reading glasses
uh
and then the person in the store showed
me these and they were like
60 euro i thought yeah but pretty handy
so that's what i got
ah
what do you think about the idea of the
silent period that is the idea should
hold off trying to speak and just to
input for a while until you are ready so
i don't believe in the sort of religious
silent period apparently there's a
school in thailand where
people are learning thai in thailand and
the teacher says you are not allowed to
speak until you know he gives the word
or something and so you're in thai
surrounding thailand surrounded by ties
and you're not supposed to speak i think
that's a little bit silly i think we
should speak when we feel like speaking
or when we have the opportunity i don't
think there's any necessity to speak
early i think the major emphasis for a
long long time is input
listening and reading but when we have
the opportunity to speak sure speak and
i find now that i've started speaking
earlier because the many stories has
given me more phrases and more sort of
high frequency verbs that i can use
and but even at that once a week an hour
in each language is what i'm doing so
i don't think there's any hard and fast
rules but i think the focus for a long
long time is on input rather than output
and particularly if the output focuses
on trying to save things correctly which
is typical of traditional language
instruction
i'm not sure that that's sort of helpful
it builds up a lot of anxiety in the
learner
hello from algeria
uh how many words did you know when
you're in chinese because you said that
you were reading
so uh
yeah yeah i i think i have about three
four thousand uh characters in chinese
uh well does the kind of content have an
influence on your motivation yes
obviously content of interest content
that's familiar uh a voice like the
audio pleasant voice all of these things
influence your motivation
well the many stories be available for
every language at link if you know we
have paid for some we've had volunteers
for some we paid for the most you know
popular languages if people
oh yeah you know what
just a second
okay
you know what i'm just gonna finish up
i'm just gonna
finish up my um video here i forgot i
have my arabic conversation here so
thank you for listening bye for now
that's okay